fragen auf unsere fragen zu dieser
epidemie die uns nach wie vor sehr
beschäftigt und zu diesem virus von
denen wir immer noch nicht allzu viel
wissen
antworten wird wieder der biologe martin
stürmer leiter eines labors in frankfurt
und immer noch in häuslicher quarantäne
hallo herr stürmer das letzte mal haben
wir letzte woche gesprochen da sind sie
kreise aus dem risikogebiet
zurückgekommen vom skifahren haben sich
selber sofort unter häusliche quarantäne
gestellt war das die richtige
entscheidung war die richtige
entscheidung weil wir haben jetzt weiß
ich auch ich habe jetzt mein positives
testergebnis nachdem ich in den
initialen testung negativ war relativ
schnell symptome entwickelt und insofern
war es absolut die richtige entscheidung
das zu tun um nicht den betrieb im labor
nach lahmzulegen andere mitarbeiter zu
infizieren
das heißt sie haben einen ersten test
gemacht der erste test war negativ und
haben sie gewartet dann kam der zweite
nach dem 6 7 tagen und der ist jetzt
positiv genau in eine positive test in
der familie und dann geht man eigentlich
auch davon aus dass der rest der familie
ebenfalls infiziert ist aber wie gesagt
als mitarbeiter im medizinischen labor
gelten natürlich ein paar andere
maßstäbe und dementsprechend einmal den
test wiederholt und jetzt mit dem
positiven ergebnis ist auch eindeutig
klar dass ich infiziert bin können sie
das mal beschreiben wie sich das anfühlt
ist es tatsächlich so etwas anderes oder
denkt man so ja gott ist halt husten mit
fieber ja manchmal denkt anders würde
ich mal von mir persönlich brauche nicht
auch im gespräch mit vielen gesagt es
ist für mich so vom gefühl zu geben
mit so die idee schwerste erkrankungen
so erkältungs mäßig die in den letzten
jahren jahrzehnten mitgemacht habe aber
da mag auch der psychologische aspekt
des neuen dahinter stehen und ja doch
mit über 50 und mit einem bluthochdruck
vielleicht doch auch zu der risikogruppe
zu gehören
die doch eher mal so schweren verlauf
hat als der mittdreißiger ohne
irgendwelche grunderkrankung das mag ein
psychisch auch eine rolle gespielt haben
dass ich das ganze etwas intensiver und
bewusster wahrgenommen habe
das heißt lagen sie richtig ein paar
tage flach und konnten gar nicht mehr
aufstehen und haben sich nur noch mit i
ging schleppt das tatsächlich ist mir
ein vormittag ging es mir relativ
schlecht das war war der samstag da sich
ein vormittag auf der couch schon wusste
nicht wie ich mich drehen sollte vor
lauter rückenschmerzen
das hat sich dann aber relativ schnell
auch gegeben aber das war so der
augenblick wo ich dachte jetzt mal
gucken wie es weitergeht und ob du nicht
doch vielleicht später ins krankenhaus
muss die haben sich schleppen wir haben
schon immer häufig gesagt ich glaube
trotzdem dass noch mal wichtig worauf
sollte ich achten wenn ich den verdacht
habe ich habe dieses virus eingefangen
wir haben die light symptomatik primär
ist es der wussten das ist das fieber
ist der husten trocken oder feucht
nein das ist definitiv trocken das ist
der iraner wüssten ganz klassisch es ist
trocken
das heißt er tut weh in der lunge beim
husten nicht muss ich mal in der lunge
wehtun
die infektion fängt zum glück nicht
direkt in der lunge an wenn sie das tut
werden wir sicherlich bei den patienten
schweren verlauf haben sondern fängt
oben im rachenraum an die infektion und
dann wird das immunsystem an zu arbeiten
und wenn es alles normal läuft verbleibt
die infektion auch er oben und wandert
nicht in die lunge weil wenn sie da
hingeht und das immunsystem ist noch
nicht bereit
dann kommt es eben zu den schweren des
schwersten verläufen gut dann hoffen wir
mal dass die davon verschont bleiben
sieht aber derzeit ganz gut aus sie sind
jetzt mit ihrem positives ergebnis der
test ist heute nachmittag abend positiv
gewesen
dh der ist jetzt noch nicht in den
aktuellen zahlen drin
ich bin jetzt noch eine nullnummer für
die statistik so sieht's aus genau das
ist eine frage mit der wir uns erst mal
beschäftigen wollen denn die zahlen vom
robert koch institut die jeden tag in
der pressekonferenz verkündet werden die
sind immer noch ein bisschen anders als
die von der amerikanischen johns hopkins
universität die sind nämlich immer schon
höher
das ist eine sache die wundert viele
menschen die das sehr intensiv
beobachten und mein kollege andreas hack
hat mal nachgeforscht woran das liegt
schulschließungen kontaktverbot zeigt
dass schon wirkung in den fallzahlen
insgesamt und in der zahl der täglichen
neuinfizierungen vorgestern gab sich das
robert koch institut vorsichtig
optimistisch
wir sehen den trend dass die
exponentielle wachstumskurve sich etwas
abflacht
ich kann ihnen aber sagen dass ich
diesen trend wahrscheinlich am mittwoch
also übermorgen definitiv bewerten kann
aber ich bin optimistisch dass diese
maßnahmen schon jetzt sichtbar sind die
kurve der insgesamt infizierten in
deutschland steigt weiter steil an
erst wenn sie deutlich flacher wird wäre
das ein zeichen für eine entspannung
die zahl der neuinfizierten gibt etwas
zuversicht aber sie schwankt der grund
manche gesundheitsämter übermitteln die
zahlen tagesaktuell andere melden sie
erst am folgetag und am wochenende gibt
nur ein teil der behörden die daten
weiter es kursieren zudem
unterschiedliche zahlen die johns
hopkins universität aktualisiert rund um
die uhr und nutzt neben den angaben der
gesundheitsämter weitere quellen
die whu das internet regionale medien
gewissermaßen eine hochrechnung das
robert-koch-institut aktualisiert nur
einmal täglich deshalb sind dessen
amtliche zahlen niedriger in der tendenz
ähneln sie sich aber die zahl der nicht
bekannten infizierten also die
dunkelziffer ist ein weiteres problem
der statistiken
lothar wieler konnte heute dann doch
richter den optimismus vom montag
anknüpfen
weiter abwarten um zu sehen ob die
maßnahmen greifen
aber im moment ist es zu früh um diese
aussagen schon belastbar treffen zu
können
die weitere entwicklung und die frage ob
ausgangs beschränkungen wirkungen zeigen
bleibt also offen ja sehr viele fragen
die wir da immer noch haben herr stürmer
wir sprechen mit ihnen sie sind leiter
eines labors in frankfurt virologe
kennen sich also ganz gut aus mit diesen
ganzen themenkomplex jetzt gucken uns
wenn diese zahlen an diese daten wie
verlässlich sind die und vor allem auch
wie wichtig ist da immer auf diese
kleinste stelle hinten zu gucken oder
reicht auch dieses pi mal daumen gefühl
ja ich denke dass es sich nicht lohnt da
hinten auf die auf tina und
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal auf die
zehner gucken zu wollen und zu sollen
die dimension ist
das was entscheidend ist sondern auch
das von 4050 oder 4025 neuinfizierte pro
tag sind ist da relativ unwichtig was
die verlässlichkeit angeht freuen wir
uns natürlich immer wenn man mal schnell
und mehrfach am tag aktualisierte zahlen
bekommen aber letztendlich sind
natürlich die zahlen des robert koch
institutes auch wenn sie diesen melde
verzug haben die offiziellen amtlichen
zahlen die letztendlich auch nach
eingang auch noch mal geprüft und
verifiziert werden
insofern wenn die statistik dann immer
vollständig ist die zahlen vorstellen
sind sind das für mich eigentlich die
zahlen mit denen ich lieber arbeite
ehrlich gesagt so wir gucken jetzt mal
in unsere kommentare denn es geht ja
darum ihr eure fragen zu diesem ganzen
themenkomplex aufzuarbeiten ich versuche
dass man bis hin zu ordnen dass das gar
nicht so einfach weil es geht von
allgemein zu speziell aber eine frage
die viele immer rumtreibt die habe ich
hier oben haben die kollegen wie die
rein geschrieben
youtube ist der kanal bibi schreibt oder
bebe weiß ich nicht ich blicke bei den
zahlen der infizierten und verstorbenen
einfach nicht mehr durch vielleicht
könnt ihr mich aufklären in italien sind
circa 70.000 infiziert und 6900 sind
daran verstorben in deutschland sind es
circa 35.000 infizierte wovon slacker
200 verstorben sind das sind ja deutlich
weniger das müssen ja selbst wenn es nur
die hälfte ist ja doppelt so viele sein
dann oder die hälfte von den italien
verstorbenen wie geht das haben wir
deutsche einfach glück oder besonders
gute gene oder wo liegt der fehler der
stürmer nein es hat mehrere gründe
weiter der der hauptgründe ist dass wir
an das testende als in italien
wir testen nicht nur in den
krankenhäusern mit testen nicht nur in
der risiko bevölkerung und wir testen
eben auch nicht nur die schwerkranken
patienten wenn ich das tool habe ich
natürlich ein verhältnismäßig hohen
anteil auch an menschen die versterben
die letztendlich in der statistik
auftauchen wenn italien als später an
die infektionen aufarbeiten kann mit zum
beispiel antikörper test und die
dunkelziffer ermitteln wird
also alle die die jetzt infiziert sind
aber nicht erfasst worden sind der
statistik wird diese rate deutlich nach
unten gehen
das muss ich wahrscheinlich ganz kurz
erklären glaube ich ein stürmer den
unterschied zwischen den test den wir
jetzt haben dieser
polymerase-kettenreaktion die ich
mittlerweile dann fast fehlerfrei sagen
kann pcr test und diesen antikörper test
wo ist der unterschied ganz laienhaft
erklären ja also der der so genannte pcr
test erfasste oder detektiert virale
erbinformationen also gucken direkt nach
dem eebus und gibt uns einen hinweis
darauf dass tatsächlich ganz akut was
passiert um das ganz vereinfacht zu
formulieren der antikörper test von dem
ich geredet habe der schaut letztendlich
nach oder mit dem schaue ich nach ob
jemand vielleicht schon mal optimieren
nicht vielleicht auch jemand diese
infektion schon mal durchgemacht hat vor
vier wochen vor drei wochen vor r8
worden zum beispiel und da kann ich dann
halt schauen inwieweit letztendlich ein
patient oder oder ein mensch in italien
oder auch in deutschland kontakt mit dem
virus hatte ohne dass er in dieser
akuten statistik die wir uns sehr jetzt
angucken wie gesagt gut fall statistik
aufgetaucht ist und wenn wir das tun und
kriegen ein viel besseres bild wie viele
menschen sich tatsächlich mit dem virus
infiziert haben
ohne eben schwer krank geworden zu sein
und dann werden diese todesfall rate
wird sich dann auch denke ich in italien
deutlich absenken und sich der unseren
annähernd es wird wahrscheinlich nicht
eins zu eins sein weil man kann die
ränder nicht vergleichen
da gibt es andere komponenten die damit
auch mit reinspielen können wir
natürlich auch gerne noch diskutieren
wenn wir die zeit dazu haben das müssen
wir gucken wie viel zeit zu sich nehmen
können und wollen sie sind ja quasi die
ganze zeit schon wieder auf sendung
aber nochmal zur frage warum testet denn
italien anders als deutschland wie so
macht man das nicht standardisiert damit
man wirklich einen vergleich hat das
wird sicherlich mit der test kapazität
auch zusammenhängen und man kann ja
nicht einfach so ein abstrich röhrchen
entnehmen und steckt das irgendwo in so
ein kleines gefäß und fünf minuten
später machte pieper und entsteht
positiv
kreativ drauf sondern dieser pcr test
erfordert schon labor seit ich einen
gewissen aufwand sowohl das personal als
auch eben gerätschaften angeht und das
muss halt eben auch in einer
ausreichenden anzahl zur verfügung
stehen und wenn man das eben nur
begrenzt hat konzentriert man sich auf
das was relevant ist und das ist
natürlich im augenblick der der schwer
kranke patient oder der kranke patient
und nicht unbedingt die breite
bevölkerung und das ist auch in
deutschland so dass wir zwar weiter
testen
aber wir können auch nicht jeden testen
es ist einfach von der kapazität her
nicht möglich
wenn ich jetzt weiter in die kommentare
in die fragen hier schaue dann gibt es
einen eine frage diese dreht sich
weiterhin um diese frage der kurven und
der zahlen von allium cepa auf youtube
also müsste die kurve jetzt wenigstens
bald mal abflachen oder wir haben auch
schon kritik bekommen an dieser kurve
die wir gezeigt haben das sei überhaupt
kein exponentielles wachstum mehr also
wie sieht das mit dieser kurve auf aus
folgerichtig wenn er die maßnahmen
effektiv sind dann müssten wir einen
bestimmten zeitpunkt sehen dass die
anzahl der der neuinfektionen pro tag
immer weniger wird
das sehen wir jetzt nach dem bereinigten
zahlen vom robert-koch-institut sehen
wir das noch nicht
und dementsprechend sind wir vielleicht
auch noch ein bisschen früh dran und die
maßnahmen diese ganz restriktiven
maßnahmen die sind ja auch erst wenige
tage beim aktiv insofern würde ich jetzt
mal vermuten dass wir die ganz großen
reduktionen in den fallzahlen frühestens
in der nächsten woche sehen können warum
ist das jetzt noch zu früh da die
inkubationszeit beträgt bis zu 14 tage
das heißt wenn wir zum zeitpunkt iks
eine maßnahme beschließen können sich ja
im prinzip an diesem tag noch viele
menschen angesteckt haben und die dauert
bis zu 14 tage bis die menschen in der
symptome haben
insofern haben wir da immer so ein
bisschen an gewissen nachlauf
infektionen die wir berücksichtigen
müssen und dementsprechend sieht man
auch nicht am ersten tag oder am zweiten
tag sofort die effektivität solcher
maßnahmen so jetzt sind wir hier bei den
tests mal angekommen das ist ja die
große frage wie viele tests haben wir
wie viele tests können wir machen was
zwar stand tatsächlich aus ich möchte
auch gleich noch auf diese grippe frage
kommen aber wenn wir erst mal den tests
bleiben herr stürmer gibt es hierzu eine
frage kann man so einen ptr nein einen
pcr-test auch in einem mobilen labor
machen und damit durch die city fahren
um deutlich mehr zu testen und
tatsächlich dann eine ahnung zu kriegen
waren die maßnahmen greifen und wie
sinnvoll das alles ist was wir uns
gerade an tun
ja wenn man könnte sicherlich die
gerätschaften und das personal in sontra
reinbringen das ist denke ich von der
technik möglich beschleunigen kann man
letztendlich damit nicht allzu viel weil
das einzige was man sich ein spaß ist
mehrwerte transportweg vom von der name
stelle in das labor und im labor haben
wir halt einfach besser kontrollierte
bedingungen für diese
molekularbiologischen test insofern ist
dass er keine alternative die ich jetzt
mir vorstellen könnte zurzeit aber
trotzdem haben wir ja gerade einen eher
eine knappheit an diesen tests das heißt
auch menschen die meinen sie müssten
dringend getest werden beziehungsweise
menschen die wirklich dringend getestet
werden müssen müssen wir noch warten
oder kriegen keinen test diese frage
wurde auch herr wieder gefragt der
leiter des robert koch instituts in
seiner täglichen pressekonferenz und der
hat heute dann dazu folgendes gesagt
prinzipiell gilt prinzipiell dass nur
menschen getestet werden die symptome
zeigen hier gibt es ein paar
ausschlaggebende kriterien hatten sie
kontakt mit einem bestätigen cupid 19
voll gehören sie zu einer risikogruppe
oder gehören sie zum medizinischen
personal oder wenn die menschen schwer
krank sind haben wir keine andere die
katze also keine differentialdiagnose
wir gehen davon aus dass diese änderung
dabei helfen werden die ressourcen für
tests gezielter einzusetzen dass ärzte
einfach besser priorisieren können denn
natürlich haben wir nicht so viele fest
dass man die einfach sinnlos einsetzen
kann sondern wir müssen gezielt
strategisch sinnvoll gezielt diese tests
einsetzen
so strategisch gezielt sinnvoll diese
tests einsetzen
das klingt total toll herrscht immer die
reden gerade mit manchen stürmer einem
virologen in frankfurt mein eindruck ist
aber dadurch dass wir so eine dezentrale
struktur haben überall sind es labore
die haben sich zu testlabor verbünden
zusammengeschlossen über sind
gesundheitsämter die verschiedene
vorgaben machen
ist das jetzt einfach nur ein schönes
wort von herrn wieder dass wir das
strategisch sinnvoll einsetzen sollen
und das passiert gar nicht so richtig
weil jeder seine eigenen maßnahmen macht
oder passiert das doch was ist ihr
eindruck
die neuen testkriterien teilweise mit
der staunend zur kenntnis genommen weil
es gibt da einen punkt der der mich doch
etwas erstaunt hat weil letztendlich ein
mensch der erkältungssymptome hat auch
sich kann testen lassen kann ohne dass
er oder sie kontakt mit risikopatienten
oder mit risikogebieten gehabt hat dann
steht netterweise in klammern dahinter
wenn die test kapazität ausreichend ist
also man macht sich das glaube ich im
augenblick doch ein bisschen zu einfach
es klingt klingt seine letztendlich
bleibt die verantwortung immer bei dem
arzt oder bei dem zentrum die diese
patienten erstmalig sehen und letztlich
entscheidet immer noch der arzt habe die
kriterien für ihn ausreichend
diese dieser untersuchung anzufordern
ein verbrieftes recht auf den test hat
hat hat keiner von uns und nein das ist
natürlich sinnvoll diese ganzen tests
ressourcenschonend einzusetzen weil
irgendwann wie gesagt laufen wir auch
über mit mit testen in den laboren und
dann gibt es diese zertifizierung die
keiner möchte und es kann uns natürlich
auch passieren wenn mehr und mehr
patienten wirklich schwerer krank werden
dass wir uns dann tatsächlich auch wie
andere länder auch mehr auf diese
konzentrieren müssen was die tester aber
was heißt das konkret hersteller ich
habe zum beispiel freunde die haben die
deutlichen symptome die haben husten
schmerzhaftem husten und die haben
fieber immer immer wieder in schüben am
tag
die ärztin sagt bleiben sie bitte
einfach 14 tage zu hause in tests
bekommen sie nicht weil sie sind nicht
in einem beruf der jetzt systemrelevant
ist also wir brauchen sie nicht
wir müssen nicht wissen ob sie das ding
haben aber das ist ja eigentlich
ärgerlich möchte doch gerne wissen ob
man jetzt diesen diesen virus hat und
danach erstmal durch ist oder ob man
sich dann weiter schützen muss wie ein
irrer genau das ist für den mit
einzelnen betroffenen ist das
nachvollziehbar ärgerlich also kann ich
hundertprozentig nachvollziehen
auf der anderen seite wie gesagt wenn
wir jetzt diese menge an betroffene wir
sind immer noch in der erkältungssaison
wenn ich jetzt alle menschen die die
wenn sie mal um fragen wer hat
erkältungssymptome wer fühlt sich gerade
seit ein paar tagen nicht nicht wohl und
hat diese dann bekomme ich so viele
menschen auf einmal zusammen die ich
testen müsste dass wir im labor einfach
kollabieren und überlastet sind unter
das kann ja auch nicht der sinn sein und
dementsprechend so blöd ist wie gesagt
für den einzelnen ist wenn man die
symptome hat lohnt es sich wie gesagt
tatsächlich mit seinem arzt zu sprechen
wenn er oder sie dann sagt ja wir können
den test ich veranlasste ihn dann hat
man gut und wenn man ihn nicht bekommt
geht man als person einfach davon aus
dass man vielleicht auch infiziert ist
hält sich an die vorgaben an die
quarantäne häusliche quarantäne für 14
tage wenn die symptome nach 14 tagen
verschwunden sind und man war auch zwei
tage davon wirklich symptomfrei dann
kann man davon ausgehen dass man dann
tatsächlich auch die infektion
durchgemacht hat so wir haben jetzt hier
ist einmal zwei fragenkomplexe die sich
in den kommentaren aufgelaufen oder
aufgelaufen sind das eine dreht sich um
die maßnahmen und das andere dreht sich
eher um die prävention um das virus an
sich ich würde jetzt erstmal mit diesen
generellen fragen zu dem virus anfangen
und da kommt immer wieder die frage wie
lange bleibt das virus in der luft
bestehen hier von fahrrad auf facebook
wahrscheinlich nicht allzu lange es ist
so dass wir das virus eigentlich nur in
die in der umgebungsluft übertragen oder
über gehirn mit den tröpfchen wenn wir
einmal kräftig pusten also wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel jetzt hier einmal in
den raum husten würde ohne in die
armbeuge zu husten würde ich einen
treffenden ebel erzeugen um diese
tröpfchen haben eine gewisse
sinkgeschwindigkeit und die ist
jetzt hier in geschlossenen räumen nach
tropfengröße ein zentimeter in der
minute bei den ganz kleinen tröpfchen
also relativ lange aber draußen an der
frischen luft verwirbelt unheimlich
schnell diese tröpfchen wollte sie
singen zu wohnen ist damit potenziell
ungefährlich und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass wir alle in die armbeuge husten
auch tatsächlich das habe ich auch
gerade erst gelernt nicht nur noch
pusten damit eben diese tröpfchen die
wir nicht sehen nicht die luft kommen so
ist es und deswegen auch dieser
sicherheitsabstand von 12 15 bis 2 m
weil sie können noch so kräftig wussten
sie werden das nicht allzu viel weiter
verteilen können ihre tröpfchen wollen
gehen wir weiter zu fragen die sich um
dieses virus trainer otto prantl möchte
wissen stimmt ist das gerippe geimpfte
menschen ein höheres risiko bei coop 19
haben also in dieser krankheit
tatsächlich zu erkranken
das werden wir neu die grippeimpfung an
sich stimuliert das immunsystem sorgt
dafür dass die antikörper gegen
grippeviren gebildet haben und das hat
letztendlich mit einer kurve 19
erkrankungen nichts zu tun also vielen
dank auto trentl für die frage dass da
gerade gesehen gehen glaube ich sehr
sehr viele merkwürdige informationen
durch die welt also toll dass wir das
alles abfragen können
dann möchte michael wird wissen wie soll
man denn wissen ob man nur träger ist
das virus wenn viele menschen haben ja
nicht wirklich symptome kann man das
überhaupt irgendwie wissen
nein wissen kann man es nicht
insofern das ist mir vorhin schon mal
waren mit dieser mit dieser test frage
kann ich mich testen lassen damit es
endlich weiß symptomatische also
patienten die keine symptome oder nur
ganz ganz milde symptome und das nicht
merken können natürlich potenzielle
überträger sein merken tut man das nicht
es gibt wie gesagt ein paar
risikoszenarien und da kann ich wieder
aus eigener erfahrung erzählen weil wir
eben zum skilaufen in tirol gewesen sind
und denn dort irgendwann auch tirol als
risikogebiete erklärt worden ist wenn
man sich einem solchen aufgehalten hat
und selbst wenn man dann nicht unbedingt
kann man in après ski bars sich
aufgehalten
hat man es dann doch irgendwie die
chance bekommen das virus zu tragen also
jeder der da so ein bisschen letzter
zeit im skiurlaub war der kann zum
beispiel überlegen ob er oder sie dann
vielleicht doch einer der träger des
virus sein kann auch ohne die symptome
danke dass man auf ich glaube youtube
ich bin seit einer woche positiv
getestet symptome seit elf tagen das
wird schon relativ lang
meine frau hat asthma und war schon vor
der erkrankung in chur bald kommt sie
nach hause wann bin ich nicht mehr
ansteckend ganz wichtige frage
das stört es ist eine sehr wichtige
frage die die sogenannten frei
testkriterien geltende 14 tage nach
symptombeginn frühestens dann müssen die
letzten zwei tage davon symptomen
freiwasser reise alten kriterien ich
muss noch mal einen haken kriterien
heißt prinzip kriterien nach denen man
als nicht mehr infektiös gilt okay man
ist die karte denn auch hätte verlassen
dürfen wenn es die kontaktsperre nicht
geben würde
14 tage wie gesagt seit dem beginn der
symptome jetzt hat ja gesagt elf tage
glauben sind diese thomas schon also
fehlen noch drei und letzten zwei tage
müssen auch symptomfrei gewesen sein
und dann gilt man als nicht mehr
infektiös also wenn ich jetzt hier dass
man darin einen rat geben wollen
zusammen dann heißt es ja elf tage wenn
es morgen nicht besser wird dann besser
die frau nicht treffen und das mit dem
arzt besprechen wahrscheinlich ne so
sieht's aus also es gibt daten dass man
bis zu acht tage nach den symptomen
infektiöses material aus dem rachen raum
noch nachweisen oder oder gewinnen
konnte also infektion so viren
nachweisen konnte
und da ist das sicherlich ein
sicherheitspuffer aber gerade eben mit
mit asthma als als grunderkrankung und
dann auch denn deswegen schon cool
gewesen das riecht ja dafür da deutliche
vorsicht walten zu lassen
ok dann wünschen wir von hier aus alles
gute und wir hoffen dass es
läuft bei ihnen herr großmann eine
interessante frage
ich muss mal kurz gucken hier das wird
gerade schon getippt augenblick wie
wahrscheinlich ist dass das virus
mutiert und gefährlicher wird möchte
backstein junior wissen es wird notieren
das mutiert wahrscheinlich auch schon
wir werden lernen müssen ob es stärker
als in freelancer oder weniger stark
mutiert aufgrund seiner gehen struktur
würde ich jetzt eher mal sagen es wird
nicht ganz so mutations vor dick sein
wie influenza viren aber das wird die
zukunft zeigen
erfahrungsgemäß motivieren er in
richtung sich besser vermehren zu können
und noch effektiver vermehren zu können
und da ist eben besser für einen virus
den menschen nicht schwerer krank zu
machen nicht nicht noch weiter
einzuschränken weil als wird soll der
mensch ja möglichst das virus effektiv
verbreiten und wenn ich mit der
infektion noch irgendwie zu hause liege
mich gar nicht bewegen kann der kreis
virus auch nicht gut verbreiten an
anderen menschen und strategie und
evolution geht eher in die richtung der
der optimierten verbreitung und deswegen
vermutlich eher dass wir eher in
richtung weniger gefährlich gehen werden
was die mutationen angeht da haben sie
gerade ein wichtiges stichwort gesagt
influenza es wird ja höre ich immer
wieder auch in diskussionen mit freunden
mit bekannten grippewelle haben wir doch
auch jedes jahr sterben so und so viele
tausend menschen immer dran teilweise
auch unentdeckt wenn menschen sind
wochenlang krank warum dann keine
maßnahmen wie wir sie jetzt haben und
jetzt aber schon müsste man das nicht
bei jeder influenzawelle genauso
handhaben
ja ich bin ein bisschen bei ihnen was
was die weniger aufmerksamkeit der der
klassischen den freelancern die medien
in den letzten jahren angeht
auf der anderen seite gegen eine
influenza kann ich mich aktiv schützen
was ich selber auch immer ist ja fleißig
touren dem ich mich impfen lasse
und ich habe die möglichkeit wenn ich
erkranke
und rechtzeitig solche influenza
erkrankte erkannt zu werden kann nicht
medikamentös auch den verlauf der
krankheit deutlich abmildern
weil das können wir beim neuen corona
virus bis dato nicht ich kann mich weder
mit einer impfung schützen doch habe ich
im augenblick medikamente zur verfügung
mit denen ich den krankheitsverlauf
abschwächen kann
insofern waren wir natürlich wenn ich
die absolute zahlen mir anschaue
weniger froh mit 19 tote als als zweiter
influenza noch aber dass sie nochmal ja
noch genau sie sagen wollte ich nämlich
gerade angst aber das wird sich nach es
wird sich definitiv wird sich das ändern
wir stehen am anfang der der epidemie
mit unserem neuen krone virus und ich
glaube dass sich die zahlen da schon
auch anders noch in relation gegeben
werden das ist eine sache die sie gerade
sagen da habe ich heute bin ich
innerlich zusammengezuckt als herr
wieder das in seiner pressekonferenz
sagte vom robert-koch-institut wir
stehen am anfang einer epidemie gefühlt
dauert das arbeit glaube ich allen
menschen in deutschland jetzt schon viel
zu lange und man würde einfach gerne mal
wieder zur normalität zurück gehen was
heißt denn das jetzt also wir stehen am
anfang einer epidemie und wir haben
eigentlich denken darüber nach was kommt
eigentlich danach müssen wir diese
diskussion echt noch zwei drei monate
verschieben befürchte ich ja also ich
glaube nicht dass wir zu ostern die
normalität zurückkehren werden sondern
es wird jetzt viel davon abhängen ob die
maßnahmen wirklich erfolg haben werden
bei der reduktion der neuinfektionen pro
tag ob wir die kurve wirklich abflachen
können und dann haben wir ja ein
weiteres problem wir haben ja noch nicht
die hertie mobilität erreicht von
geschätzt 60 bis 70 prozent der
bevölkerung damit ebenso eine pandemie
sich dann auch irgendwann mal mal
totläuft sondern durch das verzögern
aber natürlich diese diese immunität
auch verzögert und da ist es jetzt
glaube ich entscheidend wie schnell der
impfstoff wirklich marktreif und
verwendbar wird in der breiten
bevölkerung
um vielleicht dann doch über kurz oder
lang ist zu schaffen da zu einer
gewissen normalität zurückzukehren also
es werden spannende spannende monate
also wie gesagt ostern glaube ich nicht
so sein wie letztes jahr will ich
eigentlich sogar ziemlich sicher dann
kommt passt die frage von jessica
schäfer müller auf facebook wie lange
sind denn aus dass beschränkungen
sinnvoll hier ich mag es mal kurz für
euch das hier sehen könnt
beziehungsweise wenn alles wieder normal
läuft dann kann das sich doch schnell
wieder ausbreiten das ist ja auch glaube
ich so dass in die befürchtung in china
die gestern mit großem propaganda bohei
gesagt haben juve haben es geschafft
ja absolut richtig und das virus ist ja
dann nicht verschwunden nur weil wir
jetzt in deutschland dann vielleicht
nicht mehr so viele neue infektionen pro
tag sehen und da kann man dann nicht
wenn man sagt so jetzt haben wir die
kurve abgeflacht jetzt nehmen wir alle
maßnahmen zurück wird genau das
passieren was sie gesagt hat es wird
virus wird wieder kommen in voller
stärke also da müssen wir sehr
vorsichtig sein und immer tagesaktuell
möglicherweise sogar schauen was ist
möglich und richard uns ist allen
bewusst dass solch rigiden maßnahmen
nicht nur für uns betroffene sondern
auch für die wirtschaft
über kurz oder lang katastrophal
ausgehen werden also man wird irgendwann
auch gezwungen seien vonseiten der
behörden über lockerung oder über
veränderungen der maßnahmen nachdenken
zu müssen
wahrscheinlich auch und jetzt auch schon
die köpfe was die aktion gibt und ich
bin mal gespannt wie es da in den
nächsten wochen bis monaten weitergeht
da kommt noch eine frage hier die passt
ganz gut da rein die betrifft
tatsächlich auch mich persönlich weil
ich habe ein ähnliches problem zu hause
vorerkrankungen jasmin götze möchte
wissen auf youtube wie ist das denn mit
chronisch kranken kindern
ich markiere das kurz für euch hier ist
es nicht leicht sind nicht sie ende
april zur schule zu schicken in meinem
fall dann zur tagesmutter wie kann man
sie schützen also klar irgendwann müssen
wir die kinder wieder in die schule
schicken oder in die kindertagesstätten
über die kann man denn jemanden schützen
deren schwaches immunsystem hat er schon
probleme mit den atemwegen und muss man
die zu hause behalten laufen die mit
masken rom was würden sie sagen ja ja ja
also irgendwas in der richtung hinaus
laufen müssen
weil gerade in gutem schulkind alter je
nachdem welcher für welches alter wir
reden wird man über abstand halten und
netiquette
bisher wussten etikette reden können
aber spätestens im kindergarten gehört
dass auch weil die kinder spielen
zusammen die nehmen irgendwie alles
mögliche in den mund da jetzt wird es
extrem schwierig die die wunde haben
kinder hat da großartig zu schützen also
ich kann ihnen da auch kein
allheilmittel nennen ich glaube dass da
tatsächlich die die weitere isolierung
besser ist in der hoffnung dass er
vielleicht ja doch irgendwann
irgendetwas finden und nur einen
mundschutz einem kleinen kind auch zu
setzen halte ich auch für schwierig weil
der und schutz ist zehn minuten später
liegt euro in der ecke ja das kann nicht
bestätigen so ich sage jetzt erst mal
danke herr stürmer aber ich wollte sie
noch mal fragen gibt es irgendetwas was
sie es noch mal loswerden wollen weil
wir stellen aber die fragen manchmal
vergessen wir ja auch sachen gibt es
einen aspekt der ihnen wichtig ist den
sie noch mal loswerden möchten ja ich
kann weiterhin nur an alle appellieren
weiter so zu machen dass jetzt erst mal
die die ausgangs beschränkung so weit
wie möglich eingehalten werden es lohnt
sich nicht in panik zu verfallen wir
sollten alle wirklichen gehörigen
respekt vor situationen und vor dem
virus haben ich kann es am eigenen leibe
beschreiben das ist kein zuckerschlecken
und ich denke wenn wir da alle zusammen
gemeinsam durchgehen aber auch eine gute
chance einigermaßen aus dieser situation
wieder herauszukommen
aber es erfordert auch geduld jedes
einzelnen und wirklich ein miteinander
und der rücksichtnahme auf andere
hersteller an vielen dank für diese
letzten worte dann sage ich danke euch
für eure fragen aber eine sache haben
wir noch und zwar in eigener sache
das hat jetzt mit dem thema an sich gar
nichts zu tun das geht nämlich um
unseren online-auftritt und unsere app
die zdf heute die heute de heißt ab
heute zdf heute wir haben unsere app
komplett renoviert wir haben sie
aufgeräumt
es gibt jetzt ganz tolle sachen es gibt
themen specials wir haben so eine art
stories gebaut wie man das von instagram
oder facebook kennt
es gibt es interaktive webseiten wo man
sich dann genauer zu einem thema
informieren kann unter anderem auch zum
corona virus wir haben live stream sind
natürlich alle sendungen zum nachschauen
falls ihr die heute app schon
installiert habt einfach mal kurz
aktualisieren wenn das noch nicht getan
habt wer ist jetzt ein guter zeitpunkt
weil es lohnt sich
und in diesem sinne sage ich aber
erstmal jetzt für diesen live stream
vielen dank fürs zuschauen wir sehen uns
morgen wieder und bis dahin macht's gut
und tschüss und wenn euch dieser stream
gefallen hat dann guck doch mal hier
vielleicht in den beitrag rein da war
meine kollegen darf eine flieger
unterwegs und hat versucht nach den
grands schließt wenn man aus polen
wieder rauszukommen
oder vielleicht hier gibt es einen
beitrag zu den ganzen falschmeldungen zu
corona und außerdem hier unsere playlist
da könnt ihr euch durch fühlen